&gt;&gt; Well honestly Andy, I'm not sure. You said it had to do with how fast the waves
are shaking. But the only difference I see here, is how spread out the waves
are.
&gt;&gt; That's a really great point Lauren. This is what's hard about drawing waves.
Waves are moving all the time. And when we draw them we have to draw them
still. But your putting out when you say the wave is stretched out, maybe from
here to here. This is called the wavelength of the wave. But for now, I think
Susan actually brought her slinky with her today, so maybe we can go to Susan.
Susan, are you there with your slinky by any chance?
&gt;&gt; Way ahead of you Andy. Once you started talking about waves, I got a contestant
here to help out.
&gt;&gt; That's great Susan.
&gt;&gt; And Susan, do you think you could actually shake your hand up and down really
slowly and make a nice low frequency wave for us?
&gt;&gt; Sure thing, Andy. Here is a large stretched out wave.
&gt;&gt; It is. Now what happens if you shake your hand a little faster?
&gt;&gt; Here, it gets much more compact.
&gt;&gt; So, high frequency waves are squished together, and low frequency waves are
spread apart?
&gt;&gt; That's right, exactly. So, high frequency waves have a short wavelength.
Whereas, low frequency has a long wavelength. thanks a lot Susan. It looks like
we're actually getting ready for the next event.
&gt;&gt; Yep, we'll be ready soon.